نعم نحن الان فعليا يعني في العد التنازلي
بعد يومين بدايه الشهر المقبل سيكون حفل
الزفاف يعني منذ فتره طويله هو اول حفل
زفاف ملكي سيكون بدايه الشهر المقبل طبعا
انا في احد الشوارع التي سيمر بها الموكب
الاحمر موكب زفاف ولي العهد والاميره رجوى
سيكون هناك اغلاقات لبعض الشوارع وبعض
المنافذ او الشوارع الفرعيه المغذيه لها
من الساعه الثالثه بعض الظهر حتى الساعه
السابعه مساء سيتجه الموكب الاحمر من قصر
زهران وهو اقدم القصور وشهد الكثير من
الاعراس وحفلات الزفاف الملكيه من قصر
زهران وصولا الى قصر الحسينيه سيكون عقد
القران ستكون هناك راويه وعادل سبع مواقع
احتفال ستنقل يعني مراسم الاحتفال مباشره
قبل شاشات كبيره ليتسنى للمواطنين رؤيتها
والمشاركه فيها ايضا هناك ترتيبات
للمواطنين ستكون هناك حافلات سميت
بالحافلات المكوكيه سيكون هناك 26 موقعا
يمكن للمواطنين من يمين الموكب وشمال
الموكب المشاركه بالاحتفال ويعني صعود هذه
الحافلات المكوكيه لانتقال بسهوله ويعني
عدم يعني عرقله الشوارع وبذلك ستكون
الاحتفالات هذه احتفالات يعني ينتظرها
طبعا الشعب الاردني لانها حفل ولي العهد
والاميره رجوى طبعا قبل حفل الزفاف بيوم
يعني يوم غدا سيولم العاهل الاردني الملك
عبد الله الثاني حفل عشاء سيدعو عليه او
دعا عليه طبعا وجهاء عشائر ومسؤولين
ووزراء وممثلي ابنائي المخيمات يعني اطياف
من المجتمع الاردني للمشاركه بهذا الحفل
الذي يعد حفلا للشعب الاردني وليس فقط حفل
للعائله المالك عادل بالتاكيد دامت افراح
الاردن عامره يعني
بديارهم عامره ان شاء الله شكرا ناسها
جميل لمتابعه المزيد الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات